every year Netflix ups the game with its
original content in fact the streaming
service will soon boast 1,000 original
movies and shows in its library you'll
probably never be able to watch them all
but there's no denying that there's
truly something for everyone available
the company is already hard at work
putting out tantalizing glimpses of
their 2019 lineup from a gangster film
by Martin Scorsese to a brand-new
superhero series 2019 is shaping up to
be an epic year here's a look at
everything we know about the 2019
Netflix originals that are sure to blow
you away
the Irishman barely five years ago it
would have been insane to suggest that
Martin Scorsese would direct a direct to
streaming feature but now that video
on-demand services are backing
oscar-winning films like Amazon's
Manchester by the sea it's safe to say
that the landscape has changed and with
Netflix willing to dump billions in the
pot for new original content who can
blame Scorsese for working out a
production deal the result sees the
Goodfellas director going back to his
roots with the Irishman a mob epic
starring Robert De Niro as Frank Sheeran
the Hitman allegedly responsible for the
disappearance of Jimmy Hoffa De Niro
isn't the only big name attached
Al Pacino is on board to play Hoffa with
Joe Pesci Harvey Keitel and Anna Paquin
co-starring
the Central Park five with the
hard-hitting documentary xiii ava
duvernay proved beyond a shadow of a
doubt that she could handle sensitive
real-life struggles in a way that
resonated with Netflix's audience so it
should come as no surprise that the
streaming service is tapping her for an
in-depth dive into one of the most
infamous crimes of the 80s in 1989 New
Yorker Tricia Miley was jogging in
Central Park when she was assaulted
police subsequently arrested five
teenagers who were convicted and
sentenced to prison
it wasn't until over a decade later that
the real perpetrator confessed proving
the five young men to be innocent the
Central Park five will be a scripted
drama series that explores the aftermath
of the crime from the media circus
surrounding the trials to the young
men's eventual release from prison
it should offer an emotional look into
how the case affected the lives of
everyone involved sex education one of
the bright spots of 2019 should be
Gillian Anderson's return to the small
screen after leaving both the x-files
and American Gods she slated to star in
sex education as Jean a therapist and
working mom who's trying her best to
raise her son Otis who's a bit of an odd
duck he's a virgin who knows more about
getting busy than any of his sheets
shaking classmates asa butterfield who
you may know from Ender's Game stars as
Otis and the series is slated for a
tentative 2019 release date the last
dance in the 90s there was only one name
that mattered in basketball Michael
Jordan as the scoreboard stacking star
of the Chicago Bulls Jordan became both
an athletic legend and a pop culture
icon he brought whole stadiums to their
feet with his buzzer beaters and rim
rattling dunks with the last dance
Netflix is teaming up with ESPN to
deliver a one-of-a-kind look at the
sports climate of the early 90s when air
jordan soared to stardom the ten part
documentary series will combine
interviews with jordan and his former
teammates along with archival footage of
the Bulls final bid for one more
championship in 1998 put it all together
and it should be a unique enthralling
experience for any sports fan polar from
Bond villain to cannibal genius Maz
Mickelson has practically done it all
which is why it's almost surprising that
he's found yet another exceptionally
unique project to tackle Netflix's
upcoming polar is based on polar came
from the cold a graphic novel that
follows a retired assassin who's forced
back into his old ways after an attempt
on his life the concept began life as a
webcomic before Dark Horse picked it up
and turned it into a graphic novel and
it's about as crazy as you'd expect from
its hyper violence to its Bleak neo-noir
trappings Poehler came from the cold is
certainly an experience and we're hoping
the film finds a way to capture that
insanity pickle sin is taking the lead
role with Vanessa Hudgens and Katheryn
Winnick
signed on to CoStar razing Dion in 2015
writer and director Dennis Liu wrote and
released a comic book series called
raising Dion accompanied by a trailer to
promote it the comic follows a single
mother who realizes that her
seven-year-old son Dion is developing
superpowers it's a unique completely
different type of superhero story than
many people are used to and the first
issue snagged plenty of fans it didn't
take long for Netflix to take notice
ordering a ten episode series with Blu
at the helm this series will follow the
same story as the comic with Alicia
Wainwright starring as Dion's mother and
Michael B Jordan as her husband in a
climate filled with superheroes of all
shapes and forms
Raising Dion definitely looks like an
original take on the genre Dolomites is
my name Eddie Murphy has flown way under
the radar for the past two several years
so it's big news that he's set to appear
in a new project in Dolomites is my name
he stars as Rudy ray Moore a comedian
and actor best known for starring in the
1975 exploitation film Dolomites Moore
had a long varied career in both
stand-up and the film industry so there
really isn't a better actor to bring him
to life the supporting cast is just a
star studded with Wesley Snipes TI &
keegan-michael key all set to appear
even Chris Rock was spotted on set
decked out in the kind of outfit that
could have only come from the 70s